françois poulet mathis à quel type de
réaction doit-on s'attendre ce soir de
la part de l'union européenne
aujourd'hui on peut considérer que
vladimir poutine a franchi un pas un pas
décisif parce que et s'est mis une
certaine manière il faut dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont en violation du
droit international puisqu'il reconnaît
finalement des parties d'un autre état
donc ça c'est une violation du front
international au delà de ça il ya une
véritable problématique c'est que j'ai
écouté attentivement polymère food in à
l'instant ce qu'il semble dire c'est que
l'ukraine c'est la russie c'est la
russie éternelle c'est la russie
historique la russie anciennement
soviétique et donc quelque part c'est la
partie de la russie qui a été volée qui
a été volée par des séparatistes par des
gens qui sous influence occidentale
finalement se sont laissés aller à
fomenter une réaction nationaliste qui
finalement est à l'origine de tout cela
et puis il ya aussi effectivement ça
c'est une réalité la réalité de l'otan
lorsque toutes les républiques issues de
l'ancien bloc soviétique se sont
détachés lorsque tous ces pays de l'est
ont pris leur indépendance qui n'était
plus satellite il avait besoin
effectivement à ce mandat d'une
protection cette production ils l'ont
trouvée avec l'otan donc effectivement
les promesses qui je le rappelle n'était
que moral du secrétaire d'état james
baker de promettre que l'alliance
n'irait pas au delà de l'allemagne et
bien effectivement tout ça était
nécessaire pour le sentiment qu'avait
cpi de leur sécurité est ce qu'il faut
en déduire effectivement que là on va
vers une confrontation oui dans la
mesure où effectivement un pas a été
franchi oui où il y avait violation du
droit international mais non dans la
mesure où la diplomatie est toujours
possible tant que les troupes
soviétiques qui sont je le rappelle
massé tout autour de l'ukraine elle
entoure l'ukraine complètement qu'on ne
dise pas que ça ne crée pas un sentiment
finalement d'insécurité pour les
ukrainiens eux mêmes et bien toute cette
mousse et si ses troupes soviétiques
devait rentrer sur le territoire actuel
de crenn tel qu'il est reconnu par le
droit international et bien là on
franchira un pas de plus et là on on
risquerait une véritable confrontation
beaucoup plus grave et donc je crois que
ce que ne comprend peut-être pas
vladimir poutine c'est que les européens
ni les occidentaux d'ailleurs n'ont pas
envie de faire hier ils ne sont pas
contre la russie ils en ont marre de la
guerre la guerre c'est ça suffit pour
vécu à une certaine époque ils ne
veulent plus sale guerre donc ils
veulent effectivement un arrangement ils
veulent discuter alors comment discuter
bien tout simplement en disant que
l'adhésion de l'ukraine à l'otan n'est
pas d'actualité elle peut paraître
l'actualité puisque on ne peut pas
intégrer un pays est en guerre
actuellement donc ça dépend de
l'actualité d'autre part il y a des
efforts à faire pour que chacun se
comprenne il n'y a pas dans le monde les
bons d'un côté et les méchants de
l'autre parce que des deux côtés il y
avait effectivement des attitudes qui
sont parfaitement condamnables donc si
on ne fait pas un minimum d'effort pour
dire non mais il ya moyen de 100 ans
pour éviter et faire tomber cette
pression parce que si vladimir poutine
mais en pratique ce qu'il vient de dire
c'est à dire éventuellement être prêts à
envahir les deux républiques de lui en
ce qu est de donetsk les républiques du
nord basse s'il le fait effectivement
c'est un pas de plus vers un conflit
pour on ne peut pas savoir où il
s'arrête avant